From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
OK. Let's agree on facts.
好吧，让我们先就事实达成一致。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
We all had hope of going to USA.
我们都怀揣着去美国的希望。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
Nairobi, Kenya. Saturday, the day after President Trump signed his executive order temporarily stopping all refugees from entering the United States. This is a transit center for refugees, run by the International Organization for Migration, the IOM, which helps them relocate.
肯尼亚，内罗毕。周六，也就是特朗普总统签署行政命令，暂时禁止所有难民进入美国后的第二天。这是一个由国际移民组织（IOM）运营的难民中转中心，该组织负责帮助他们重新安置。
In a tent, about 40 Somalis sit on plastic chairs-- mostly men. They're banned from the United States for two reasons, if you want to get technical about it. Because they're refugees, and because they're from one of the seven countries where we're banning all travelers-- from Somalia.
在一个帐篷里，大约 40 名索马里人坐在塑料椅子上——大部分是男性。如果非要讲究细节的话，他们因为两个原因被禁止进入美国。因为他们是难民，而且他们来自美国禁止所有旅客入境的七个国家之一——索马里。
A middle aged Kenyan, George Okech, stands in front of them with the unenviable job of explaining the news. Many of these men were supposed to fly in the next two or three days.
一位名叫乔治·奥克奇的中年肯尼亚人站在他们面前，负责解释这个消息，这是一个令人不快的差事。这些人中的许多人原本预计在未来两三天内就要飞往美国。
And as it is now, you know that there is a new president in the office of USA.
目前的情况是，你们知道美国有一位新总统上任了。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
So for this reason, are you are aware that some changes will come in?
所以出于这个原因，你们意识到会有一些变化吗？
[Somali]
[索马里语]
For your information, it's not only in Kenya, but many other places, too.
通知你们一下，不仅在肯尼亚，在其他许多地方也是如此。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
This is beyond our control. We don't have a final say here. Are you aware of that?
这超出了我们的控制范围。我们在这里没有最终决定权。你们意识到这一点了吗？
Yeah. I mean, people are really sad, just some of them with their heads in their hands.
是的。我是说，人们真的很伤心，有些人甚至双手抱头。
Kevin Sieff is the Africa bureau chief for The Washington Post. He was there recording what happened for us.
凯文·西夫是《华盛顿邮报》非洲分社社长。他在那里为我们记录了所发生的一切。
Some of them had been refugees for 25, 26 years. I would say probably the majority of them had been refugees for more than two decades.
他们中有些人当难民已经 25、26 年了。我想他们中的大多数人当难民已经超过二十年了。
Oh, my God.
天哪。
Yeah. And so I mean, these are people, in many cases, who submitted their applications to go to the US 10, 12 years ago. And that's how long it took them to get to this step in the process, this last step.
是的。我的意思是，在很多情况下，这些人早在 10、12 年前就提交了去美国的申请。他们走到这一步，也就是最后一步，花了这么长的时间。
This last step, though, is now blocked.
然而，这最后一步现在被堵死了。
What the president has said is final. We can't question him.
总统所说的就是最终决定。我们无法质疑他。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
It is final for me.
对我来说这是最终决定。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
Final for IOM.
对国际移民组织来说是最终决定。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
Final for you.
对你们来说是最终决定。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
Neither you or us should start fighting about it.
无论是你们还是我们，都不应该为此争吵。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
So the process now will be people will have to go back to the camp.
所以现在的流程是，人们将不得不回到营地。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
The camp is the refugee camp seven hours away, where they lived.
营地就是七小时车程外他们居住的那个难民营。
So we have just to move you back there.
所以我们只能把你们送回那里。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
As we all wait.
当我们都在等待的时候。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
How would you take that?
你们打算怎么接受这个结果？
[Somali]
[索马里语]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[嘈杂的人声]
The problem with moving back is, OK, everything. But the practical part of it is daunting. They sold their homes and possessions, gave up their jobs. And they were no longer on the books as camp residents. People running the camp weren't sure what to do with that. George asked the group, what are some of the problems?
回去的问题在于，好吧，一切都要重新开始。但实际层面的困难是艰巨的。他们卖掉了房子和财产，放弃了工作。而且他们不再是登记在册的营地居民了。经营营地的人不确定该怎么处理这些事。乔治问大家，他们面临的问题有哪些？
What are some of the problems that you are facing if you go back may I ask you? One by one, not everybody. One by one.
如果你们回去，面临的问题有哪些，我可以问问吗？一个一个来，不要同时说。一个一个来。
Yes, Mr. Ahmed?
好的，艾哈迈德先生？
[Somali]
[索马里语]
He is in 26 years.
他在营地待了 26 年。
26?
26年？
Yes.
是的。
At the camp?
在营地吗？
At the camp level, yes.
在营地层面，是的。
He's saying he's been at the camp for 26 years.
他说他在营地待了 26 年。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
And when he was called by IOM to go for flights, he took, for shopping, clothes credits from one of the shopkeepers. And that shopkeeper is expecting him to pay back that credit.
当他接到国际移民组织的电话准备登机时，他向一名店主赊账买了衣服。那个店主正等着他还债。
Kevin, just explain what's being said here.
凯文，解释一下这里在说什么。
So before these guys left their refugee camps, they bought a lot of clothes to bring with them for the journey. The clothes are cheaper there and they kind of wanted to arrive already having American clothes, already having winter jackets. I think there was this idea that they could come out of whatever American airport they'd arrived at and already be prepared. There was a lot of pride, I think, attached to that.
所以在这些人离开难民营之前，他们买了很多衣服带在路上穿。那里的衣服更便宜，他们想在抵达美国时就已经穿上美国的衣服，准备好冬装。我想他们认为他们可以从美国的任何一个机场走出来时就已经准备好了。我觉得这其中带着很多自尊。
But, Kevin explained to me, because they didn't have any money, they bought all the clothes on credit with the idea that they were going to earn the money in America and then send it back.
但是，凯文向我解释说，因为他们没有任何钱，所以他们都是赊账买的衣服，想着到了美国后赚钱再寄回去。
And so that was one of their biggest concerns was how are they going to pay back this huge sum of money. They'd never considered it. And so even if they only spent, I don't know-- I think most of them spent around $100 on clothes. That's an unimaginable amount of money to make for almost all of these people.
所以他们最大的担忧之一就是如何偿还这笔巨款。他们从未考虑过这种情况。所以即使他们每人只花了，我不知道——我想他们大多数人在衣服上花了大约 100 美元。对他们中的绝大多数人来说，这是一个无法想象的巨款。
Because working a job in the camp, how much would you make a day?
因为在营地工作，一天能挣多少钱？
Some of the highest paid people in the camp are teachers, and they make $80 a month. So to pay back $100-- they're really worried about having these confrontations with the people who they basically borrowed large sums of money from.
营地里收入最高的人是老师，一个月也就 80 美元。所以要偿还 100 美元——他们真的很担心会和那些借给他们大笔钱的人发生冲突。
So George tells the refugees.
于是乔治告诉难民们。
Your creditors--
你们的债主——
[Somali]
[索马里语]
You'll have to talk to them.
你们得和他们谈谈。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
Because you are not yet in America.
因为你们还没到美国。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
And it wasn't to your liking.
而且结果不尽如人意。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
And if you promise that you are going to work hard to pay back.
如果你们承诺会努力工作来偿还。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
That is something explainable to somebody.
那是可以向别人解释的事情。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
It is not easy.
这不容易。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
But it is something that we have to swallow, though bitter.
但尽管痛苦，我们还是得忍受。
George calls in another guy, a skinny guy in his 20s with a goatee. He used to be a headmaster of a school in the camp. He says that, while he was waiting for his papers to come to the United States, he turned down scholarships in Canada and Germany. The one in Canada included a path to citizenship. And he did that because he wanted to go to America. After the four-month temporary ban, he asks, are we going to be allowed into the United States? George replies.
乔治叫了另一个人，一个 20 多岁、长着山羊胡的瘦高个。他过去是营地里一所学校的校长。他说，当他等待去美国的证件时，他拒绝了加拿大和德国的奖学金。加拿大的那个还包括获得公民身份的途径。他这样做是因为他想去美国。在四个月的临时禁令之后，他问，我们还能被允许进入美国吗？乔治回答说。
Remember I said that this is a bitter pill and there is nothing we can do about it. We don't want to give you any false promise. We don't know what will be said and put into effect by the end of 120 days. The boss has said wait. And once he has said wait, nobody will change it till he decides otherwise.
记住我说过这是一剂苦药，我们对此无能为力。我们不想给你们任何虚假的承诺。我们不知道 120 天结束时会有什么说法和实施细则。老板说等。一旦他说等，在他决定改变之前，没人能改变它。
[Somali]
[索马里语]
The boss? He means President Trump.
老板？他是指特朗普总统。
Yeah, that's right.
是的，没错。
This is like the worst town hall meeting ever. It's like each person stands up and says something awful about the situation, and then the guy in the front of the room says, yes, this is a bitter pill.
这简直是有史以来最糟糕的市政厅会议。就像每个人站起来说了一些关于现状的可怕事情，然后屋子前面的那个人说，是的，这是一剂苦药。
And there's also just no clarity for them. One of the things that struck me while I was at the transit center is that every time someone prepared to speak to the refugees, there was this false hope. Like, they all gathered around in these plastic chairs and waited for good news. And it happened a lot. They were gathered around in a group and basically told that nothing had changed. But each time before that person, like George, started speaking, there was this expectation. And you could feel it that maybe they're going to say now that the suspension's been lifted.
而且他们也完全没有方向。在转运中心时，有一件事让我印象深刻，那就是每当有人准备对难民讲话时，都会产生一种虚假的希望。他们就像这样聚集在塑料椅子上等待好消息。这种情况发生了多次。他们聚在一起，被告知什么都没有改变。但在乔治这样的人开始讲话之前，总有一种期待。你能感觉到，也许他们会说禁令已经解除了。
Fact is, at the end of 120 day ban on entering the United States, for many, if not most, of these refugees, clearances and their applications will expire. So they're going have to clear those again, which could take years.
事实上，在 120 天禁止入境的禁令结束时，对于这些难民中的大多数人（如果不是全部的话）来说，他们的许可和申请都会过期。所以他们将不得不重新申请，这可能需要几年时间。
Our country does lots of things around the world that have unintended consequences, but this is the intended consequence of the travel ban. These refugees were stopped until the administration could toughen up the vetting process to enter the United States. In the first week of the Trump administration, there was a lot of talk about dealing with illegal immigrants to the US, about building a wall, about how we were going to pay for that.
我们的国家在世界各地做了很多有意外后果的事情，但这是旅行禁令的预期后果。这些难民被拦截，直到政府能够加强进入美国的审查程序。在特朗普政府执政的第一周，有很多关于处理非法移民、建造围墙以及我们如何支付费用的讨论。
But immigrants who followed the rules, who filled out the forms, who went through the process-- they were fine. Not this week. With the signing of this executive order, the president made the transition from cracking down on illegal immigrants to cracking down on legal ones. All the people at this camp were legal immigrants. They'd gone through a rigorous vetting process that had taken years, had been approved for resettlement, and now they're barred from the country.
但是那些遵守规则、填写表格、走完流程的移民——他们原本没事的。但这周不是这样。随着这项行政命令的签署，总统完成了从打击非法移民到打击合法移民的转变。这个营地的所有人都是合法移民。他们经历了长达数年的严格审查程序，获准重新安置，现在却被挡在国门之外。
Today on our radio show, we're going to document some of the things that happened when the executive order went into effect, and we're going to talk about the way it was implemented. As I'm guessing you've already heard, customs agents didn't have clear instructions. Government agencies said they weren't properly consulted. There was no advance warning to agencies or to travelers, so people got on planes and then had to be turned back from airports. It was like seeing a major policy change thrown into the world like a fastball with no warning. And it's hard not to feel like, what just happened? Like, what was that all about? We talk about that, too.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们将记录行政命令生效时发生的一些事情，我们将讨论它的实施方式。正如我猜你们已经听到的那样，海关人员没有明确的指令。政府机构表示他们没有得到适当的咨询。机构和旅客没有得到任何提前警告，所以人们登上了飞机，然后不得不被机场拒绝入境。这就像看到一项重大政策变更毫无预警地像快球一样被扔向世界。而且人们很难不感到困惑，刚刚发生了什么？这是怎么回事？我们也讨论了这个问题。
About half the country approves of the ban according to a Reuters poll. But if you took a poll at this transit center, I'm pretty confident the numbers would not be that high. Kevin talked to one guy, Ahmed, who's 24. Born in the refugee camp. And until he went to the transit center, he said he'd never been outside the camp.
根据路透社的一项民意调查，大约一半的美国人赞成这项禁令。但如果你在这个中转中心进行民调，我相信比例不会那么高。凯文采访了一个叫艾哈迈德的 24 岁小伙子。他出生在难民营。直到他来到这个中转中心，他说他从未离开过营地。
And that's really common at that camp in Dadaab. Dadaab is the biggest refugee camp in the world. There are 270,000 people there.
这在达达布的那个营地非常普遍。达达布是世界上最大的难民营。那里有 27 万人。
It's very sad. Can I ask you a question?
这太令人难过了。我可以问你一个问题吗？
Yeah.
当然。
Are you from America?
你是美国人吗？
Yeah, I'm from America. It's called Fort Lauderdale.
是的，我来自美国。那个城市叫劳德代尔堡。
So how do you feel, only surrounds that city?
那你感觉如何，只待在那座城市周围？
He's asking you, how would you feel if you never left Fort Lauderdale?
他在问你，如果你从未离开过劳德代尔堡，你会感觉如何？
How would you feel? You personally?
你会感觉如何？你个人？
Yeah, I think it would be hard. And also, Fort Lauderdale is much bigger than your camp.
是的，我觉得那会很困难。而且，劳德代尔堡比你们的营地大得多。
Exactly. Yeah. That's how is it.
正是如此。是的，就是那种感觉。
So let me ask you. When you're sitting in Ifo camp and you're trying to imagine America-- far away; it looks different-- how do you imagine it in your head?
所以让我问你。当你在伊福营地坐着，试图想象美国时——很遥远；看起来很不一样——你在脑海中是如何想象它的？
In fact, when I had started this process, I used to just dream at night that I, in America, I'm just driving a bus. You see, just walking--
事实上，当我刚开始这个过程时，我晚上经常做梦，梦见我在美国，我正在开公交车。你看，就这样走着——
You're driving a bus in the dream?
你在梦里开公交车？
Wait, wait. He's saying that in his dream of living in America, he's a bus driver?
等等，等等。他是说在梦里生活在美国，他是一个公交车司机？
Yeah. That's the thing that he really latched onto.
是的。这是他真正执着的事情。
Why do you think in the dream you were driving a bus? I'm just wondering.
为什么你觉得在梦里你在开公交车？我只是好奇。
I like driving.
我喜欢开车。
Have you ever driven a car?
你开过车吗？
No.
没有。
You've never driven a car?
你从来没开过车？
I never drive a car here. [INAUDIBLE] America around there.
我从来没在这开过车。[听不清] 在美国那儿。
It case this isn't clear, these are literal dreams, like while he was asleep. He would be in America, driving a bus, and then Ahmed said he would wake up and, you know, he'd be back at the camp.
以防不清楚，这些是字面意思上的梦，就像他睡觉时那样。他会梦见在美国开公交车，然后艾哈迈德说他会醒来，然后，你知道，他会回到营地。
So after working their way through the application process-- some of them taking a decade doing it-- Ahmed and the other Somalis find out at the 11th hour, no, they are not going to America. And in fact, they're going to be returning to the refugee camp where they'd given up their jobs and their homes. And in fact, they were now in debt for their new American winter coats and pants.
所以在走完申请流程之后——有些人花了几十年时间——艾哈迈德和其他索马里人在最后一刻发现，不，他们去不了美国了。事实上，他们将要回到那个他们已经放弃了工作和家的难民营。而且实际上，他们现在还因为那些新的美国冬装和裤子背上了债务。
I mean, I can tell you that after they heard this speech from George, within 15 minutes, everyone was in their rooms with their blankets pulled over their faces. And I mean, it was just really, really sad. There were a lot of people who were going to the clinic, a lot of people who were refusing to eat, a lot of people who were refusing to take their medication. There were concerns at the center that people might try to kill themselves. They had extra security there because they weren't sure what people were going to do, that people might kill themselves.
我的意思是，我可以告诉你们，在他们听完乔治的演讲后，15 分钟内，每个人都躲在房间里，用毯子蒙住脸。我的意思是，这真的非常非常令人难过。有很多人去了诊所，很多人拒绝进食，很多人拒绝服用药物。中心担心人们可能会试图自杀。他们增加了额外的安保，因为他们不确定人们会做什么，担心人们可能会自杀。
Then, six days later, as you've probably heard, a judge in Washington issued a restraining order blocking the Trump administration's travel ban. After that, the State Department issued instructions that all the refugees who were stopped now could come to the United States and they should rebook their flights to arrive here before February 17th. That applies to these Somali refugees, who, by the end of the week, had been sent back to the refugee camp but now will be returned to the transit center to fly to the United States very soon-- unless something changes.
然后，六天后，正如你们可能听到的那样，华盛顿的一名法官发布了一项临时限制令，阻止了特朗普政府的旅行禁令。在那之后，国务院发布指令，所有被拦截的难民现在都可以来美国，他们应该重新预订航班，在 2 月 17 日之前抵达这里。这适用于这些索马里难民，他们在本周末结束时已经被送回难民营，但现在将被送回中转中心，很快飞往美国——除非情况有变。
Ahmed told Kevin that, just a few days before the executive order was signed, in the cultural orientation class to prepare them for what it's going to be like to live in America, the instructors described the country this way.
艾哈迈德告诉凯文，就在行政命令签署的前几天，在准备让他们适应美国生活的文化导向课上，讲师是这样描述这个国家的。
They said Americans, they don't discriminate people. They usually will come-- all the people, all the nations, they don't look that you came from Somalia, that you came from Kenya, from Syria, from Iran, from Russia, they don't look, from China, they don't look. All people are seen in America.
他们说美国人，他们不歧视人。他们通常会来——所有的人，所有的民族，他们不会看你是来自索马里，来自肯尼亚，来自叙利亚，来自伊朗，来自俄罗斯，来自中国，他们都不看。所有人在美国都被平等看待。
And the orientation, that was like three days ago.
而那个导向课，那大概是三天前的事。
Exactly.
正是如此。
Kevin asked him, how do you make sense of this executive order which does, in fact, single out people from just a few countries, including his. Ahmed said he didn't know how to make sense of it. He's just a student, he said. He's not a politician.
凯文问他，你如何理解这项行政命令，它实际上确实把少数几个国家的人挑出来区别对待，包括他的国家。艾哈迈德说他不知道该如何理解。他说他只是一个学生。他不是政治家。
Act One, Basket of Deportables.
第一幕，待遣返者篮子。
So the same day as those Somalis were getting that news, here in the United States at airports around the country, there were protesters, hundreds of volunteer lawyers. A lot of that was on TV. Maybe you saw it. One of our producers, Zoe Chace, was at JFK Airport, terminal 4 on Saturday as customs agents stalled out, waiting for instructions from above. Around the country, there was confusion over who to let in and who to keep out. It seemed like they were erring on the side just holding everybody till they heard from Washington.
所以就在那些索马里人收到消息的同一天，在美国全国各地的机场，有抗议者，有数百名志愿者律师。很多新闻都在电视上播了。也许你们看到了。我们的制片人之一，佐伊·蔡斯，周六在肯尼迪机场 4 号航站楼，当时海关人员停滞不前，等待上面的指令。全国范围内，对于谁可以入境谁不可以入境存在混乱。看起来他们宁可采取谨慎态度，把每个人都扣留，直到收到华盛顿的消息。
Zoe hung out with the lawyers for a while, like Becca Heller from the International Refugee Assistance Project. Her team had been at the airport since the night before, trying to get information from Customs and Border Protection, CBP.
佐伊和律师们待了一会儿，比如来自国际难民援助项目的贝卡·海勒。她的团队从前一天晚上就一直待在机场，试图从美国海关及边境保护局（CBP）获取信息。
When we talked to CBP last night and asked who we could speak to, they told us to call the president.
当我们昨晚联系 CBP 并询问我们可以和谁谈话时，他们告诉我们要给总统打电话。
Donald Trump.
唐纳德·特朗普。
Yes. They specified that the president was Donald Trump in case we weren't aware of that. So a lot of our clients who were being held yesterday, Customs and Border Patrol just kept telling them, we're waiting for a call from DC to tell us what to do.
是的。他们明确指出总统是唐纳德·特朗普，以防我们不知道。所以我们昨天扣留的很多客户，海关及边境保护局只是不停地告诉他们，我们正在等华盛顿特区的电话告诉我们该怎么做。
Really?
真的吗？
And I don't know who was supposed to be on the other end of the phone. Is Mike Pence calling them up and telling them what to do? Nobody knows.
我不知道电话那头应该是谁。是迈克·彭斯打电话告诉他们该怎么做吗？没人知道。
All day the lawyers couldn't see their clients. Zoe and the other reporters couldn't see them or talk to them. They were hidden away somewhere back in the airport. And there's all this mystery about what was happening with these people who had arrived from the seven banned countries.
一整天律师们都见不到他们的客户。佐伊和其他记者也见不到他们或与他们交谈。他们被藏在机场后面的某个地方。关于这些从七个被禁国家抵达的人，发生了什么事情充满了神秘。
In the days that followed, over the course of this week, Zoe tried to answer that question about what was going on back there.
在接下来的几天里，在这一周的时间里，佐伊试图回答关于后面发生了什么的问题。
While Becca and I and the masses of other reporters and lawyers were stuck in the arrivals terminal outside the Dunkin' Donuts, here's what her client Haider was doing right at this moment. He was sitting quietly among dozens of people with no phone in a little room just a few minutes walk from where we were. He'd started off in another terminal, trying for hours to ask the customs officer, what's going on?
当我和贝卡以及大量其他记者和律师被困在到达航站楼外面的 Dunkin' Donuts 时，这就是她的客户海德尔此刻正在做的事情。他静静地坐在几十个人中间，没有电话，在一个离我们步行只需几分钟的小房间里。他从另一个航站楼开始，试图花几个小时问海关官员，发生了什么事？
What's the problem? Relax. Relax. Sit down. Relax.
有什么问题吗？放松。放松。坐下。放松。
You know, my English isn't that great, so I would ask like, what's the problem? They'd be like, sit down. Relax.
你知道，我的英语不是很好，所以我问的是，比如，有什么问题吗？他们就会说，坐下。放松。
I reached Haider by phone a few days after the JFK episode. We spoke through an interpreter. He says when he got off the plane, he never even made it to customs. There were lots of people waiting around, which confused him. And a woman led him into a little room.
在肯尼迪机场事件发生几天后，我通过电话联系到了海德尔。我们通过翻译进行了交谈。他说当他下飞机时，他甚至都没到达海关。有很多人在等着，这让他很困惑。一个女人把他带进了一个小房间。
[Arabic]
[阿拉伯语]
They still had my passport, and so I was there like four hours just sitting and waiting.
他们拿走了我的护照，所以我就在那儿坐着等了大约四个小时。
Haider had been trying for three years to come to America. He fled Iraq a year and a half ago, found his way to Sweden. His wife had worked for an American contractor in Baghdad and their lives were threatened because of it. She and their son have been in Houston for those three years, trying to get him a visa. He got that visa to come to the United States on January 27, 2017. That was executive order day. His flight left Stockholm at 12:00 PM New York time on Friday. While he was in the air, the order went into effect. Haider didn't know that. He didn't know the order existed, that things have changed. His mind was racing.
海德尔为了来美国已经努力了三年。他一年半前逃离伊拉克，设法到了瑞典。他的妻子曾为巴格达的一家美国承包商工作，他们的生命因此受到威胁。她和他们的儿子在那三年里一直住在休斯敦，试图为他拿到签证。他在 2017 年 1 月 27 日拿到了来美国的签证。那一天是行政命令发布日。他的航班于周五纽约时间下午 12 点从斯德哥尔摩起飞。当他在飞机上时，该命令生效了。海德尔不知道。他不知道该命令的存在，不知道事情发生了变化。他的脑子飞速运转。
[Arabic]
[阿拉伯语]
I'm telling them like, I can't go back to Iraq. I can't go back there, and I can go back to Stockholm because I gave up my right to be there once I came here. And I did everything, and it took three years. And my family's already living here. I have my wife and my son and my wife's family, and everybody's in Houston. And I did this, and it took me three years. Then you told me to come. I'm coming, and now you're telling me I can't come.
我告诉他们，比如，我不能回伊拉克。我不能回那里，我也回不了瑞典，因为我一旦来到这里，我就放弃了在那里的权利。我做了所有事情，花了三年时间。我的家人已经住在这里了。我的妻子、儿子、我妻子的家人，所有人都住在休斯敦。我做到了这一切，花了我三年时间。然后你们告诉我来。我来了，现在你们告诉我我不能来。
He couldn't call his wife, Dunya, who was waiting in Houston, but she had a good idea why he might be late. She had Fox News on Friday afternoon.
他无法给在休斯敦等待的妻子邓雅打电话，但她很清楚他为什么会迟到。周五下午她开着福克斯新闻。
I was at work, and I just put the headphones in my ear, and I was listening. And I just broke down when I heard the news. I just left. I couldn't stay in my place.
我在上班，我只是戴上耳机，听着新闻。听到消息时我崩溃了。我直接走了。我没法待在原地。
You were crying.
你在哭。
Yeah. It was a really hard time for me.
是的。那对我来说真的很难熬。
And what were you scared of?
你怕什么？
I'm scared because if they let him go, all the three years is going to be returned again, you know?
我怕的是如果他们让他走，那三年的努力就全白费了，你知道吗？
You'll have to just do the whole three years over, the whole vetting process.
你将不得不重来三年，整个审查流程。
Yeah.
是的。
Back at the airport, Haider was stood up against a wall and searched. They put him in handcuffs. They took him to a car.
在机场，海德尔被带到墙边搜身。他们给他戴上了手铐。他们把他带到了一辆车里。
[Arabic]
[阿拉伯语]
Like, I don't know. Like, I can't-- I can't describe it. It was just-- you're just there. This is the first time in my life somebody has ever put handcuffs on me-- and without reason, too. The first time in my life.
我不知道。我没法——我无法描述。这只是——你就待在那里。这是我一生中第一次有人给我戴上手铐——而且还是无缘无故的。我一生中的第一次。
In the car was an Iranian and another Iraqi also in handcuffs. They drove to terminal 4, the terminal where the lawyers and I were. He got taken into another room. CBP took the handcuffs off and told them why they were there.
车里还有一个伊朗人和另一个也被戴上手铐的伊拉克人。他们开车去了 4 号航站楼，也就是律师和我所在的航站楼。他被带进了另一个房间。海关及边境保护局解开了手铐，并告诉他们为什么在这里。
[Arabic]
[阿拉伯语]
One of the officers was telling us that this is what Trump said. If you're from this country, if you're from Iraq, and even if you have a visa and everything, you're still going to be sent back to your country. Then I was saying, I was in Sweden before this. I had a visa there and everything. You can't send me back to Iraq because the second I get set back there, I'm going to die.
其中一名警官告诉我们，这就是特朗普所说的。如果你来自这个国家，如果你来自伊拉克，即使你有签证和其他所有东西，你还是会被遣返回国。我当时说，我在这之前在瑞典。我在那儿有签证什么的。你不能把我遣返回伊拉克，因为我一旦被送回那里，我就死定了。
And what did they say to you when you said that?
当你这么说时，他们对你说了什么？
[Arabic]
[阿拉伯语]
He said, I can't do anything for you.
他说，我帮不了你。
[Arabic]
[阿拉伯语]
I was just at that point that I just went and I sat. And I was just like, I don't know if we were all allowed a phone call or whatever, but once they kept telling you and telling you you're going to go back, I was almost defeated. So I was like, you have to let me call my wife and let her know what's happening because she doesn't know. So I have to let her know. And then they just gave me the phone to call.
当时我就是到了那个地步，我只是坐着。我不知道我们是否都被允许打个电话什么的，但当他们不停地告诉你，你要被遣返时，我几乎被击垮了。所以我说，你们必须让我给妻子打个电话告诉她发生了什么，因为她不知道。所以我必须告诉她。然后他们就给了我电话打电话。
Dunya, what happened in the phone call?
邓雅，通话中发生了什么？
He called me at 1 o'clock. He said, they will send me back, so don't be sad. And he said, I can't go back to Sweden, so they will send me to Baghdad. And I couldn't talk. And my sister called Julie. She's my lawyer. And she said, just tell him, don't sign anything.
他在一点钟打给我。他说，他们要把我遣返，所以不要难过。他说，我没法回瑞典，所以他们会把我送去巴格达。我没法说话。我姐姐给朱莉打了电话。她是我的律师。她说，告诉他，什么都不要签。
Yes, I am here. We have a lot of people here waiting for him.
是的，我在这里。我们这儿有很多人等着他。
Julie, the lawyer in JFK, keeps getting calls from Dunya's sister over the next few hours. She keeps her earbuds permanently in her ears and periodically shouts things out, like I am at the airport ready to assist.
肯尼迪机场的律师朱莉在接下来的几个小时里不断接到邓雅姐姐的电话。她始终把耳机戴在耳朵上，并不时大喊一些事情，比如我正在机场准备协助。
Any word on your client?
你的客户有消息吗？
Unfortunately no. Last I was told is we are waiting for the Secretary of State and Secretary of Homeland Security's signature.
遗憾的是没有。我得到的最新消息是我们正在等国务卿和国土安全部部长的签字。
I don't think we have a Secretary of State.
我不认为我们有国务卿。
Tell me about it.
别提了。
The customs official comes out at one point into the crowd of lawyers. She says, come on back, but only two congressmen, Nadler of the 10th District of New York and Velazquez of the 7th, are allowed to follow her.
海关官员在某个时刻走出来面对律师人群。她说，跟过来，但只有两位国会议员，纽约第 10 区的纳德勒和第 7 区的维拉兹奎兹被允许跟随她。
It says "no lawyers." See if you can read what they're trying to get him to sign.
上面写着“律师不得入内”。看看能不能读到他们想让他签什么。
Haider told me he stayed in that room at the terminal for another 10 hours. At some point, they brought him chicken and biscuits. One by one, he watched people leave. Haider was not interrogated, like was reported at other airports with other people who were held up. His wife waited, cried, texted the lawyers.
海德尔告诉我，他在航站楼的那个房间里又待了 10 个小时。在某个时刻，他们给了他鸡肉和饼干。他看着人们一个接一个地离开。海德尔没有像其他机场报道的那样，受到其他被扣留人员那样的盘问。他的妻子等待着，哭泣着，给律师发短信。
We asked the White House to help us understand what was happening. We got no response. But I read The Washington Post. Here's what the administration told reporters on a conference call. The news media needs to calm down their, quote, "false, misleading, inaccurate, hyperventilating coverage" of the, quote, "fractional, marginal, minuscule percentage of international travelers who have simply been," as the reporter puts it, "set aside for further questioning for a couple hours on their way into the greatest country in the world." And OK, sure, a couple hours. Even 10 hours. Even 24 hours is not a big deal if you know what happens at the end-- that you get to come take refuge in America like you were promised. It is a big deal if you spend 10 hours worrying you're going to be flown off to a place where you're going to be killed, and your wife spends those hours thinking she'll never see you again.
我们要求白宫帮助我们了解正在发生什么。我们没有得到回应。但我读了《华盛顿邮报》。以下是政府在电话会议上对记者所说的话。新闻媒体需要冷静下来，他们对“虚假、误导、不准确、过度煽情的报道”进行了一些关于，引用该记者的话，“只是在进入这个世界上最伟大国家的途中，被留置进行几个小时额外问询的、极小比例的国际旅客”的描述。好吧，当然，几个小时。甚至 10 个小时。甚至 24 个小时也不是什么大不了的事情，如果你知道最终会发生什么——那就是你能够像承诺的那样来美国避难。但如果你花了 10 个小时担心自己会被飞往一个你会被杀死的地方，而你的妻子花了那些时间认为她再也见不到你了，这确实是一件大事。
6:30 PM, 22 hours later, Haider walks out into the arrivals area with everybody waiting. According to his lawyer Julie, five minutes after being told no, no, no, he cannot leave, apparently CBP suddenly changed its mind. They got a phone call and then they said, he can go. His lawyers think it's because they filed a habeas corpus suit, but really we don't know. We might never know. He came out with no documentation of what happened, which is extremely unusual.
下午 6:30，22 小时后，海德尔走出了到达区，每个人都在等着。根据他的律师朱莉的说法，在被告知不、不、不、他不能离开后的五分钟，海关及边境保护局显然突然改变了主意。他们接了一个电话，然后说，他可以走了。他的律师认为这是因为他们提交了人身保护令诉讼，但我们真的不知道。我们可能永远不会知道。他出来时没有任何关于发生什么的记录，这极其不寻常。
And so Haider is here in America with Dunya. The customs officials were nice about it when they let him go.
所以海德尔和邓雅现在在美国。当他们放他走时，海关官员表现得很友好。
[Arabic]
[阿拉伯语]
Then after, they came to me and they said, OK, we finished everything. And you can go to Dunya now.
然后，他们走到我面前说，好吧，我们完成了所有事情。你可以去找邓雅了。
[Arabic]
[阿拉伯语]
I mean, to get out there and to see all of these people that stayed up this late, and they left their homes and their jobs and everything, and they're here for the sole purpose of standing with us. It's so beautiful.
我的意思是，能出来并看到所有这些熬得这么晚的人，他们离开了自己的家、工作和一切，他们来到这里唯一的目的就是与我们站在一起。这太美好了。
It's reported later that there was basically no prep on the government's part for how to deal with this. Apparently, this executive order was signed after very little consultation with Homeland Security or the State Department or the Department of Justice-- the guys in charge of this sort of thing.
后来有报道称，政府方面对于如何处理这个问题基本上没有任何准备。显然，这项行政命令是在几乎没有咨询国土安全部、国务院或司法部的情况下签署的——那些负责这类事情的人员。
As this week went on, the more that came out, the more confused it sounded. Like the green card holders. At first, it seemed like the green card holders were banned. Homeland Security, late Friday night, said, no, not green card holders. Then the White House overruled Homeland Security, like, green card holders, still out, basically. On Sunday, the White House said, OK, fine, Homeland Security, let's just do some extra screening of the green card holders. On Tuesday, the new Secretary of Homeland Security said the rollout went smoothly. On Thursday, the White House said, never mind. No additional screening for green card holders. Also this week, Congress requested an internal investigation into the Department of Homeland Security, into the way this policy got rolled out.
随着这周的进行，披露的事情越多，听起来就越混乱。比如绿卡持有者。起初，看起来绿卡持有者是被禁止的。国土安全部周五深夜表示，不，绿卡持有者除外。然后白宫推翻了国土安全部，比如，绿卡持有者，仍然不行，基本上。周日，白宫表示，好吧，行了，国土安全部，让我们只对绿卡持有者进行一些额外的审查。周二，新任国土安全部部长表示部署过程很顺利。周四，白宫表示，算了。对绿卡持有者没有额外审查。同样在本周，国会要求对国土安全部进行内部调查，调查这项政策的部署方式。
Zoe Chace. Haider's case, by the way-- a few hours after Haider's release was the case that led a New York judge to issue the first order halting deportations under the president's ban. Others obviously followed in the days after.
佐伊·蔡斯。顺便说一下，海德尔的案例——在海德尔获释几小时后，正是导致纽约法官发布第一道指令阻止根据总统禁令进行驱逐出境的案例。随后的日子里显然还有其他人跟进。
[MUSIC - NARCY, "HEY!"]
[音乐 - NARCY, "HEY!"]
Act Two, Heavy Vetting.
第二幕，严格审查。
So the whole premise of the executive order is that we're going to stop all refugees and we're going to stop travelers from seven countries for a few months because we need to overhaul the way that we screen people before they come into the United States. Well, I talked to somebody who does that screening. He's on the staff of the United States Citizen and Immigration Services, USCIS. He's an interviewer. Flies to Africa and to the Mideast. He's interviewed Africans from all seven countries that we have temporarily banned. Sits with people for hours, drilling them on the details of their stories, looking for inconsistencies and lies. He asked that we not use his name or put his voice here on the radio, so I'm going to call him Bob. We have an actor, Scott Shepherd, saying what he said here on the air.
行政命令的整个前提是我们要在几个月内阻止所有难民以及来自七个国家的旅客进入美国，因为我们需要彻底改革我们审查进入美国人员的方式。嗯，我和一个负责这种审查的人谈过。他是美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）的员工。他是一名面试官。飞往非洲和中东。他面试过来自我们暂时禁止入境的所有七个国家的非洲人。他会花几个小时与人坐在一起，挖掘他们故事的细节，寻找不一致和谎言。他要求我们不要使用他的名字或在他的声音录音中提到他在电台的内容，所以我称他为鲍勃。我们找了一位演员，斯科特·谢泼德，在节目中复述他的话。
Bob said that when he and his colleagues heard about the executive order, the reaction was mostly shock and sadness. A few dozen of them went out for drinks together, and some people cried then.
鲍勃说，当他和同事们听到这个行政命令时，反应大多是震惊和悲伤。几十个人出去喝了几杯，有些人当场就哭了。
Can I ask, did you cry?
我可以问问，你哭了吗？
On my own? Yes. In front of my friends? No.
独自一人时？是的。在朋友面前？没有。
And so the news came down that this executive order came down, and so what happens to your work? What are you doing now?
所以行政命令的消息下来了，你的工作发生了什么？你现在在做什么？
When it came down, we basically came to a screeching halt. Most of us were getting on airplanes, and so we just literally had no work to do. So now we're all-- most likely, it looks like we're going to redeploy to the southern border, where we can do credible fear work. I'm not sure if you're--
当禁令下来时，我们基本上陷入了停顿。我们大多数人正要上飞机，所以我们真的没活干了。所以现在我们——很有可能，看起来我们会被重新部署到南部边境，在那里我们可以做可信恐惧的相关工作。我不确定你们是否——
Do you mean you'll be doing with the border with Mexico, where you'll be doing credible fear work? That's people who want asylum and you have to interview them to figure out if they have a credible fear of getting killed?
你是说你会去美墨边境做可信恐惧工作？也就是那些想要庇护的人，你必须面试他们以确定他们是否有对被杀害的合理恐惧？
Right, right.
对，对。
Now, the whole premise for this executive order is that our ways of screening people to come into this country from these particular countries is not strong enough, and we're not doing a good enough job. And the president wants to put in something that he's calling extreme vetting. What do you think of that idea?
现在，这个行政命令的整个前提是我们从这些特定国家进入这个国家的审查方式不够强大，我们做得不够好。总统想要引入他称之为“极端审查”的东西。你觉得这个主意怎么样？
I find it personally offensive because it implies that those of us who vet refugees weren't doing extreme vetting before, that the work that I do as a refugee officer wasn't adequate to begin with. And I take the security of our country as my first priority. So I would never let someone in who I was suspicious of.
我个人觉得这很冒犯，因为它暗示我们这些审查难民的人之前没有进行“极端审查”，暗示我作为一名难民官员所做的工作本来就不够充分。我把我们国家的安全放在第一位。所以如果我怀疑某人，我绝不会让他们进来。
Bob and I talked for a while about the vetting procedures that are in place now. And they are considerable. People are fingerprinted. We take biometric data. In many countries, there are iris scans. Security checks are run by the FBI, the CIA, the Department of Defense, the National Security Agency, the National Counterterrorism Center, and sometimes others. They look at criminal databases and terrorism watch lists. They check family members' affiliations. They'll call contacts on people's smartphones. They have document verification labs. They compare the biometric information. And of course, they check people's social media accounts.
我和鲍勃谈论了一会儿现行的审查程序。它们已经相当繁琐。人们会被采集指纹。我们采集生物特征数据。在许多国家，有虹膜扫描。安全检查由联邦调查局、中央情报局、国防部、国家安全局、国家反恐中心以及有时其他机构进行。他们查看犯罪数据库和恐怖主义观察名单。他们检查家庭成员的从属关系。他们会拨打人们智能手机上的联系人电话。他们有文件核查实验室。他们对比生物识别信息。当然，他们会检查人们的社交媒体账户。
The interviews Bob does are face to face. They take hours. A lawyer that I talked to who advocates for refugees seeking asylum, Laura Finkbeiner from the International Refugee Assistance Project, emphasized how these interviews are customized for each person.
鲍勃进行的面试是面对面的。需要几个小时。我采访过的一位倡导寻求庇护的难民的律师，来自国际难民援助项目的劳拉·芬克拜纳，强调了这些面试是如何为每个人量身定制的。
So they have a bunch of screening questions that they've particularly crafted, and they do this based on country. So they know if you're from a certain area at a certain time, there were certain groups active there. So they're checking to see-- they're asking you questions that are based specifically on your story, and they're making sure that what you're saying is credible, so it's consistent with what they know about the area at that given time.
所以他们有一系列专门精心设计的审查问题，他们根据国家来做这些。所以他们知道如果你来自某个地区的某个时间段，那里活跃着某些群体。所以他们在检查——他们问你专门基于你的故事的问题，并确保你说的是可信的，与他们在那个特定时间段对该地区的了解相一致。
And so we are looking for discrepancies in that information.
所以我们在寻找这些信息中的差异。
I asked Bob about this.
我问鲍勃这件事。
Like, if those stories don't match, explain to me why not.
比如，如果那些故事不匹配，解释给我听为什么不。
And so basically, are you just running them through a million little details, trying to trip them up?
所以基本上，你只是在用一百万个小细节来盘问他们，试图让他们露出破绽？
For the most part, yeah.
大部分情况下，是的。
And this has become an incredibly politicized question, but I hope you can answer it honestly. Are there times in your job where you feel like, oh, I really can't tell about this person and I wish I had more tools? I wish there was more I could do to figure this out better?
这个问题已经变得非常政治化，但我希望你能诚实回答。在你的工作中，有没有感觉，哦，我真的无法判断这个人，我希望能有更多的工具？我希望我能做更多的事情来把这件事弄清楚？
There are times that, because it's impossible to know about some people for whatever reason. But that's why we have a process. We're not letting people in that we have question marks about.
确实有几次，因为由于某种原因无法了解某些人。但这就是我们有流程的原因。我们不会让有问号的人进来。
Oh. You're saying, if you can't figure it out, then they just don't get in.
哦。你是说，如果你们搞不清楚，那他们就进不来。
Right. Right.
对。对。
And all this brings us to something that is not just Bob's opinion. Many people believe that the current vetting system is effective. They'll tell you our current system's working. And as for the rare cases where somebody gets through, they'll say no system's perfect. No system can be perfect. We need studying learned from those cases.
所有这一切让我们想到了不仅仅是鲍勃的观点。许多人认为当前的审查系统是有效的。他们会告诉你我们目前的系统运行良好。至于偶尔有人漏网的情况，他们会说没有完美的系统。没有系统可以是完美的。我们需要从这些案例中学习和研究。
One of the people who said the system is effective to me most fiercely this week was Kirk Johnson. He's been on our program before. He worked for USAID in Iraq. And then when he came back to this country, he started the List Project to help interpreters and other Iraqis and Afghans who worked with the US overseas, whose lives were threatened because of it, move to this country. In that job, he's become very familiar with how hard it can be to get somebody into the US, even if they risk their lives helping American troops. He said it's tough.
本周最坚定地向我表示系统有效的人之一是柯克·约翰逊。他以前来过我们的节目。他在伊拉克的美国国际开发署工作。当他回到这个国家时，他创办了“列表项目”，以帮助在海外协助美军而生命受到威胁的口译员和其他伊拉克人和阿富汗人搬到这个国家。在那项工作中，他非常了解让某人进入美国有多么困难，即使他们冒着生命危险帮助美军。他说这很艰难。
I'm really in this twilight zone because I'm seeing the President of the United States and his advisers try to draft policy to address a problem that doesn't exist.
我真的身处这个模糊地带，因为我看到美国总统和他的顾问们试图起草政策来解决一个不存在的问题。
And what problem is that?
那是什么问题？
Well, he campaigned by saying that we're not vetting these people. And the only way you can say that is if you don't know anything about how people are vetted. And you know, Trump's a busy guy. I don't expect him to sit down and learn the two-year vetting process in place by the US Refugee Admissions Program, but I sure as hell expect Steve Bannon or Steve Miller or any of the Steves who drafted this thing to just spend a few minutes and find out what is already in place. And I know for a fact that they did not go to the State Department's Refugee Processing people, the people that have been doing this for decades-- they never even got a basic briefing as to what currently exists.
好吧，他的竞选口号是我们在审查这些人方面做得不够。你只有在对如何进行审查一无所知的情况下才会这么说。你知道，特朗普是个忙人。我不指望他坐下来学习美国难民准入项目实施的两年审查程序，但我确实指望史蒂夫·班农或史蒂夫·米勒或草拟这个东西的任何史蒂夫，花几分钟时间去了解一下目前已经实施的内容。我知道事实上他们没有去国务院的难民处理部门，那些几十年来一直做这件事的人——他们甚至没有得到关于目前存在的情况的基本简报。
How do you know that they didn't consult with the State Department?
你怎么知道他们没有咨询国务院？
I was on the phone with the State Department minutes before he signed it, asking whether or not these people that I was pushing were going to be able to board a plane that night.
在他签署行政命令的前几分钟，我还在和国务院通电话，询问我正在推动的这些人那天晚上是否能够登机。
And this is in which office of the State Department?
这是在国务院的哪个办公室？
In the Population, Refugees, and Migration bureau.
在人口、难民和移民局。
And that's who manages these programs to figure out who can come into the country?
那是负责管理这些项目以决定谁可以进入国家的人吗？
Right.
对。
Wait. And so you were on the phone with this person while the signing was happening?
等等。所以你在签署仪式进行时还在和这个人通电话？
It was about three or four minutes beforehand, I reached out to this official at the State Department to say what's going to happen when she shows up to the airport, and he didn't know. And I said, how can you not know? Haven't they been coming and working this all out with you? And there was silence, and I pushed him. And he said, well, what do you want me to say? I'm sitting here refreshing the White House website just like you are.
就在前三四分钟，我联系了国务院的这位官员说，当她出现在机场时会发生什么，他不知道。我说，你怎么可能不知道？他们难道没有一直来和你商量处理这些事吗？电话那头一片沉默，我追问他。他说，好吧，你想让我说什么？我坐在这儿刷新白宫网站，和你一样。
Looking for the text of the executive order.
寻找行政命令的文本。
Right.
对。
We reached out to the person that Kirk talked to at the Population, Refugees, and Migration bureau to confirm this. He hung up on us.
我们联系了柯克在人口、难民和移民局交谈的那个人来确认这一点。他挂断了我们的电话。
Of course, not everybody agrees with Kirk Johnson. We reached out to two experts who have questions about how well our current system works and we asked them what's missing. How can we vet better? Mark Krikorian of the Center for Immigration Studies, which generally argues for less immigration, said we could ask more questions during the vetting process to figure out the ideology of applicants. Ask if they agree with American values. But that was the only specific thing that he could point to.
当然，并不是每个人都同意柯克·约翰逊。我们联系了两位对我们当前系统运行状况有疑问的专家，问他们缺少什么。我们如何才能审查得更好？通常主张减少移民的移民研究中心的马克·克里科里安表示，我们可以在审查过程中询问更多问题来确定申请人的意识形态。问问他们是否赞同美国价值观。但那是他唯一能指出的具体事情。
Tim Kane, who heads up immigration studies at the Hoover Institution-- not the former vice presidential candidate-- had no specific things he thought that we should add to the vetting process. He thinks it's thorough. Instead, he questioned whether we can effectively screen people at all from places like Syria and Somalia.
负责胡佛研究所移民研究的蒂姆·凯恩——不是那位前副总统候选人——对于他认为我们应该添加到审查过程中的具体事情没有想法。他认为它很彻底。相反，他质疑我们是否能够有效审查来自叙利亚和索马里等地的人员。
I don't know if it's possible to vet in a failed state. What do you do to vet people in a failed state where there's no government to serve as a source of documentation? And I think the right answer might be, it's impossible.
我不知道在一个失败的国家是否可能进行审查。你在一个没有政府作为文件来源的失败国家做些什么来审查人们？我认为正确的答案可能是，这是不可能的。
Mark Krikorian at the Center for Immigration Studies went a little further on the same point.
移民研究中心的马克·克里科里安在同一点上走得更远。
I mean, we run people's names through the databases that we have, but the state simply doesn't exist in those places. What are we going to do, run somebody's fingerprints through the Mogadishu DMV?
我的意思是，我们通过我们拥有的数据库来查询人们的名字，但在那些地方根本不存在所谓的国家。我们要怎么做，通过摩加迪沙车管所查询某人的指纹吗？
Bob, the interviewer that I talked to at USCIS, says that that's a naive picture of our security databases and the role they play in screening and the kind of information in them. And he said, in fact, Syrians, though they come from a failed state, are among the best-documented refugees. They almost always have documentation with them, he said. Like these things called family books, which are government-issued documentation of entire families.
我在美国公民及移民服务局采访的那个面试官鲍勃说，那是一种对我们安全数据库以及它们在审查中的作用以及其中的信息类型的幼稚看法。他说，事实上，叙利亚人虽然来自一个失败的国家，却是审查记录最完善的难民。他说，他们几乎总是随身携带文件。比如那些被称为“家庭簿”的东西，那是政府签发的整个家庭的文件。
None of the people we talked to this week could tell us exactly what was meant by the phrase extreme vetting. National security experts say that it's not a term that's been used in their world. Both Kane at the Hoover Institution and Krikorian at the Center for Immigration Studies said the phrase extreme vetting seems like something that Donald Trump just made up. It's a marketing term, Kane said. And the moment Donald Trump invented it seems to have been last summer, right after the attack in Nice, France. This is then-candidate Donald Trump on Fox News about four hours after the attack. Greta Van Susteren asked him what he'd be doing in this moment if he were president.
本周我们交谈过的所有人都没有告诉我们“极端审查”这个短语到底是什么意思。国家安全专家表示，这不是在他们那个世界中使用过的术语。胡佛研究所的凯恩和移民研究中心的克里科里安都表示，“极端审查”这个短语似乎是唐纳德·特朗普编造出来的。凯恩说，这是一个营销术语。而唐纳德·特朗普发明它的那一刻似乎是在去年夏天，就在法国尼斯袭击事件之后。这是时任候选人的唐纳德·特朗普在尼斯袭击事件发生约四小时后在福克斯新闻上的言论。格蕾塔·范·萨斯特伦问他如果他是总统，此刻会做什么。
Well, I'd be making it very, very hard for people to come into our country, for one thing, from terrorist areas. I would be so extreme in terms of documentation. And Obama's allowing a lot of people that come in. We have no idea who they are. They are from Syria, maybe, but they have no paperwork. Many times they don't have documentation proper. I would do extreme vetting. I would call it extreme vetting, too.
好吧，首先，我会让人们很难进入我们的国家，尤其是来自恐怖主义地区的人。在文件资料方面我会非常非常极端。奥巴马允许很多人进来。我们根本不知道他们是谁。他们可能是来自叙利亚，但他们没有任何文书工作。很多时候他们没有适当的文件。我会进行极端审查。我也会称之为极端审查。
Do you think the president just doesn't know what he's talking about when he says we need stronger vetting?
你认为总统在说我们需要更严格的审查时，根本不知道自己在说什么吗？
I know he doesn't know what he's talking about when he says that.
我知道当他这么说时，他根本不知道自己在说什么。
Again, this is Bob, who works interviewing refugee applicants. He says he, and he thinks most of his coworkers, are open to anything that could make the vetting process better. What he has a problem with is stopping the flow of refugees for four months while the administration figures it out.
再一次，这是在美国公民及移民服务局负责面试难民申请人的鲍勃。他说，他和大多数同事一样，对任何能让审查程序更好的事情都持开放态度。他真正的问题在于，在政府搞清楚它之前，停止难民的流动长达四个月。
Nobody has a problem with improving the security checks-- the process that we have to protect the United States. Nobody is going to be complaining with that. What I do have a problem with is reducing the cap of refugees that we take into the United States in the middle of maybe the greatest humanitarian crisis of my lifetime, the crisis in Syria. It's millions of people that are in need, living in camps around the world, and I feel like this is not the time to shut them out without a valid reason. Me, as an American, I feel like this is something we value, that we help the needy, that we stand up to protect people who need protection, and that's something that we're not doing.
没有人对改善安全检查有意见——我们必须保护美国的过程。没有人会对此抱怨。我真正有问题的是，在或许是我这一生中最伟大的人道主义危机——叙利亚危机——期间，减少我们接收难民的名额。那是数百万人需要帮助，生活在世界各地的营地里，我觉得现在不是在没有正当理由的情况下把他们拒之门外的时候。作为一个美国人，我觉得这是我们重视的事情，即帮助弱势群体，站出来保护需要保护的人，而这正是我们现在没有做的。
Coming up, we take apart one key sentence in the executive order and we ask, is this really true? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，我们将拆解行政命令中的一个关键句子，并问，这真的是真的吗？稍后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共电台的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, It's Working Out Very Nicely. We got that title from something the president said about the rollout of his executive order, the temporary ban on travel and resettlement.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，《运行得非常好》。这个标题来自总统关于他行政命令的部署所说的话，关于旅行和安置的临时禁令。
It's working out very nicely. You see it at the airports. You see it all over. It's working out very nicely. And we're going to have a very, very--
它运行得非常好。你们在机场看到了。你们到处都能看到。它运行得非常好。而且我们将有一个非常、非常——
A senior administration official told reporters on Sunday, quote, "it really is a massive success story in terms of implementation on every single level." White House aide Stephen Miller said later in the week, quote, "it is hard to envision a smoother rollout."
一位白宫高级官员周日告诉记者，引用他的话，“在每个层面的实施方面，它确实是一个巨大的成功故事。”白宫助手史蒂芬·米勒在本周晚些时候表示，引用他的话，“很难想象一个更平稳的部署。”
So in the first half of our radio program today, we documented what happened during some of that smooth rollout. In this half, we're going to be talking more about what we should make of its substance. And that brings us to Act Three. Act Three, Statement of Purpose.
所以在今天广播节目的前半部分，我们记录了那次平稳部署期间发生的一些事情。在这一部分，我们将更多地讨论我们应该如何看待它的实质。这让我们进入了第三幕。第三幕，宗旨陈述。
So the very first section of President Trump's executive order is called Purpose. It's the premise on which the order is based. It's the why of the whole thing. The Purpose section starts by saying, quote, "the visa issuance process plays a crucial role in detecting individuals with terrorist ties and stopping them from entering the United States." OK. No debate there. That is true.
所以特朗普总统行政命令的第一个部分叫宗旨。它是该命令的基础前提。它是整件事的原因。宗旨部分首先说，引用他的话，“签证签发过程在探测有恐怖主义联系的个人并阻止他们进入美国方面起着至关重要的作用。”好的。这一点没有争议。这是真的。
It's the next sentence that caught the eye of one of our producers, Nancy Updike. That sentence reads, quote, "perhaps in no instance was that more apparent than the terrorist attacks of September 11, 2001, when State Department policy prevented consular officers from properly scrutinizing the visa applications of several of the 19 foreign nationals who went on to murder nearly 3,000 Americans." That sounds all right-- just like a quick summary of 9/11. But Nancy had a couple questions. Here she is.
正是下一句话引起了我们制片人之一，南希·厄普代克的注意。那句话写道，引用，“也许在 2001 年 9 月 11 日的恐怖袭击中，这体现得最为明显，当时国务院的政策阻止了领事官员对那 19 名外国国民中的几个人进行适当的签证申请审查，这些人后来谋杀了近 3000 名美国人。”这听起来不错——就像 9/11 的一个快速总结。但南希有几个问题。她在这里。
The whole reason there was a commission after 9/11 that put out a 585-page report about 9/11 was to be precise and thorough about what on Earth went wrong. And if we're going to base a sea change in United States immigration policy on a one-line summary of 9/11, I want to look at whether we're getting it right.
9/11 之后成立委员会发布了一份关于 9/11 的 585 页报告，其全部理由就是为了精确而透彻地说明到底出了什么问题。如果我们要把美国移民政策的海啸级变革建立在 9/11 的一行摘要上，我想看看我们是否弄对了。
I called the senior counsel for the 9/11 Commission report, Susan Ginsburg. She wasn't just a staff member for the commission. She was team leader of the group that was focused on the visa process and border controls and how the terrorists were permitted into the country, because there's no disputing that the 9/11 hijackers came into the United States with approved visas.
我给 9/11 委员会报告的资深律师苏珊·金斯伯格打了电话。她不仅是委员会的工作人员。她是专注于签证程序和边境管制以及恐怖分子是如何获准进入国家的团队的负责人，因为 9/11 劫机者持获准签证进入美国这一事实无可争议。
Susan and her group, in fact, wrote a whole separate 241-page report just about immigration, border control, and terrorist travel. She also worked, before 9/11, for the law enforcement division of the Treasury Department, which at the time controlled customs, ATF, and the Secret Service. She also worked on counterterrorism initiatives with Richard Clarke, who led counterterrorism efforts under Presidents Bush and Clinton. Susan Ginsburg is not a softy. She asked me not to record her, but she said I could quote her if I cleared the quotes with her first. Here's what she said.
苏珊和她的团队实际上专门写了一份 241 页的独立报告，专门讨论移民、边境管制和恐怖分子旅行。在 9/11 之前，她还为财政部的执法部门工作，该部门当时控制着海关、烟酒枪炮及爆炸物管理局和特勤局。她还与理查德·克拉克一起进行反恐倡议，后者在布什和克林顿总统领导下领导反恐工作。苏珊·金斯伯格不是个心软的人。她要求我不要录音，但她说如果我先让她审核报价，我可以引用她的话。以下是她所说的。
I asked her if, in her view, it's true, as it says in the executive order that, quote, "State Department policy prevented consular officers from properly scrutinizing the visas," end quote. Susan said, there is truth in that, but it's not the whole truth. She said it's, quote, "distorted and arbitrary to focus solely on the visa process if you want to understand how the 9/11 hijackers were able to get into America," end quote. Why? Because, she said, the problem was so much bigger than that.
我问她，在她看来，行政命令中提到的“国务院政策阻止领事官员对签证进行适当审查”是否真实。苏珊说，这其中有真理，但不是全部真理。她说，引用，“如果你想了解 9/11 劫机者是如何进入美国的，仅仅关注签证过程是扭曲和武断的。”为什么？因为她说，问题远不止于此。
Before 9/11, the entire government from the president on down did not see the country's borders or its visa system as the front line of counterterrorism as we do now. The problem wasn't so much a matter of this or that policy. It was a whole mindset, a pre-9/11 mindset that was operating at all levels of government. Before 9/11, our consular offices in other countries weren't funded or staffed to do serious scrutiny of visa applicants.
9/11 之前，整个政府从总统到下级官员都没有将国家的边境或签证系统视为我们现在所认为的反恐前线。问题不仅仅是某项政策的问题。这是一种整个心态，一种在政府各个层面运作的 9/11 前心态。9/11 之前，我们在其他国家的领事办公室没有获得资金或人员配置来进行签证申请人的严重审查。
Applicants were supposed to be interviewed face to face, but a lot of times they just weren't because the word from above was that interviews were too time consuming. They slowed everything down. That might be an example of one of the State Department policies the Trump administration had in mind when it wrote in the executive order that State Department policy prevented us from properly scrutinizing visas.
申请人本应进行面对面面试，但很多时候他们只是没有，因为上面的说法是面试太费时间了。它们拖慢了一切。这可能就是特朗普政府在行政命令中写道“国务院政策阻止我们适当审查签证”时所想到的国务院政策的一个例子。
There was a terrorist watch list before 9/11 called TIPOFF, and consular officials would check names against it. But the list was frighteningly incomplete. The FBI and CIA weren't even sharing a lot of information with each other before 9/11, let alone making it available to junior foreign service officers working for the State Department overseas.
9/11 之前有一个名为 TIPOFF 的恐怖分子观察名单，领事官员会根据它核对名字。但这份名单非常不完整。9/11 之前，联邦调查局和中央情报局甚至没有相互共享大量信息，更不用说将其提供给在海外工作的国务院的初级外交事务官员了。
Customs and border agents also lacked funding and support to do real screening. Susan said, quote, "counterterrorism at the time was viewed as the purview of specialists. There was no government-wide strategic focus on counterterrorism," end quote.
海关和边境官员也缺乏资金和支持来进行真正的审查。苏珊说，引用，“当时的反恐被视为专家的领域。没有政府范围内的反恐战略重点。”
What that meant in practice with visa applications before 9/11 was that we were on the lookout for people who seemed like they might want to use a student or visitor visa to come to the US and then just stay in the country even after the visa expired because they wanted to live here. Most of the 9/11 hijackers were Saudi Arabian. Saudis at the time weren't scrutinized as potential security threats. They were seen as tourists who would most likely spend a lot of money and then go home.
这意味着 9/11 之前签证申请的实际操作是我们一直在寻找那些似乎可能想利用学生或访问签证来到美国，然后在签证过期后就待在国家里，因为他们想住在这里的人。大多数 9/11 劫机者是沙特阿拉伯人。沙特人在当时并没有被视为潜在的安全威胁。他们被视为游客，最有可能花很多钱然后回家。
To state the obvious, before 9/11 happened, we as a nation couldn't imagine 9/11. Now, 15 years later, we think about it all the time. We've spent billions of dollars to study and fix what went wrong. As Susan says, quote, "any policy or practice that was in place at the time 9/11 happened has long been superseded. Long been superseded," end quote. In other words, we wrote a whole book about this in order to change it, and the government did make enormous changes.
说得明显一点，在 9/11 发生之前，我们作为一个国家无法想象 9/11。现在，15 年后，我们一直在思考它。我们已经花费了数十亿美元来研究和修复出了什么问题。正如苏珊所说，引用，“9/11 发生时实施的任何政策或做法早已被取代。早已被取代。”换句话说，我们为此写了一整本书来改变它，而政府确实做出了巨大的改变。
I'm not saying, and Susan is definitely not saying, that now we're invulnerable. Quite the opposite. The United States is vulnerable in ways that have evolved radically since 9/11 and are continuing to evolve. But that evolution is not reflected in the executive order. The order says, correctly, that, quote, "while the visa issuance process was reviewed and amended after the September 11 attacks to better detect would-be terrorists from receiving visas, these measures did not stop attacks by foreign nationals who were admitted to the United States," end quote. That is absolutely true. But it's also true that, in the last several years, the majority of terrorist attacks in the US-- not all, but the majority-- have been committed by US citizens, not green card holders, not visa holders, not refugees. Citizens.
我并不是说，苏珊也绝对不是说，我们现在刀枪不入。恰恰相反。美国在 9/11 之后发生了根本性的演变，并且仍在继续演变，在这些方面是脆弱的。但这种演变并没有反映在行政命令中。该命令正确地指出，引用，“虽然 9/11 袭击后的签证签发过程进行了审查和修改，以更好地检测潜在恐怖分子获得签证，但这些措施并没有阻止获准进入美国的外国国民发动袭击。”这是绝对真实的。但同样真实的是，在过去几年里，美国的大多数恐怖袭击——不是全部，但大多数——是由美国公民实施的，而不是绿卡持有者，不是签证持有者，不是难民。是公民。
I talked to a former CIA case officer who said what worries him about the executive order is that it's letting the exceptions set the rule. He said ISIS propaganda doesn't need a visa. It doesn't need a plane. It's here. And to crack down right now on refugees and other visa holders, people who've been through our screening process-- to make that the focus, as if not much has really changed with our visa process since 9/11, doesn't address the biggest part of the problem right now. Which of course, doesn't mean that someone can never again get in from the outside and do terrible damage. That is always, always a risk. Susan said the government is constantly modifying security procedures as new tactics and new weaknesses emerge, and it cannot ever let up doing that.
我采访过一位前中央情报局案件官员，他说关于行政命令让他担忧的是，它正在让例外情况成为规则。他说，ISIS 宣传不需要签证。它不需要飞机。它就在这里。而现在对难民和其他签证持有者、那些经过我们审查程序的人进行打击——让这些成为焦点，好像我们的签证程序自 9/11 以来并没有太多改变，并没有解决目前问题中最大的部分。当然，这并不意味着某人永远无法再从外部进入并造成可怕的破坏。这总是、总是存在风险。苏珊说，政府正在不断修改安全程序，因为新的战术和新的弱点正在出现，它绝不能在这方面松懈。
One last thing to note about 9/11. The authors of the 9/11 report, after documenting every failure that led to 2,996 deaths, every mistake, every naive notion, after immersing themselves in this tragedy, they wrote not just that it's vital to secure the country's borders and to check and triple check everyone who wants to come here. They also wrote this. Quote, "our borders and immigration system, including law enforcement, ought to send the message of welcome, tolerance, and justice to members of immigrant communities in the United States and in the countries of origin," end quote.
最后要注意关于 9/11 的一件事。9/11 报告的作者们在记录了导致 2996 人死亡的每一次失败、每一个错误、每一个天真的想法后，在沉浸于这一悲剧后，他们写的不仅仅是保卫国家边境、对每个想来这里的人进行检查和三重检查至关重要。他们还写道。引用，“我们的边境和移民系统，包括执法部门，应该向美国和原籍国的移民社区成员传递欢迎、宽容和正义的信息。”
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our show.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制片人之一。
This idea, by the way, that security experts told Nancy that trying to stop terrorists at our borders might not be the best way to stop future acts of terror, that is also the very first point made by foreign service officers and diplomats in that dissent memo you may have heard about. The State Department has a process for its experts to call attention to policy mistakes they think the United States is making. This one was signed by about 1,000 State Department officials, apparently the most anybody can remember of signing one of these things.
顺便说一下，安全专家告诉南希，试图在边境阻止恐怖分子可能不是阻止未来恐怖行为的最佳方式，这个观点也是你可能听到的那份异议备忘录中外交事务官员和外交官提出的第一个观点。国务院有一个流程供其专家提请注意他们认为美国正在制定的政策错误。这份备忘录由大约 1000 名国务院官员签署，显然是任何人能记得的签署此类文件人数最多的一次。
This is from their memo. They said one problem with the travel ban is that it, quote, "will not achieve its stated aim to protect the American people from terrorist attacks by foreign nationals admitted to the United States. Despite the executive order's focus on them, a vanishingly small number of terror attacks on US soil have been committed by foreign nationals who recently entered the United States on an immigrant or non-immigrant visa. Rather, the overwhelming majority of attacks have been committed by native-born or naturalized US citizens-- individuals who have been living in the United States for decades, if not since birth.
这是他们备忘录中的内容。他们说旅行禁令的一个问题是，引用，“它将无法实现其宣称的目标，即保护美国人民免受获准进入美国的外国国民发动的恐怖袭击。尽管行政命令关注他们，但在美国土地上发生的恐怖袭击中，只有极少数是由最近持移民或非移民签证进入美国的外国国民实施的。相反，绝大多数袭击是由本土出生或归化入籍的美国公民实施的——这些人已经在美生活了数十年，甚至从出生起。”
Given the near absence of terror attacks committed in recent years by Syrian, Iraqi, Irani, Libyan, Somali, Sudanese, and Yemeni citizens who were in the US after entering on a visa, this ban will have little practical effect in improving public safety."
鉴于近年来叙利亚、伊拉克、伊朗、利比亚、索马里、苏丹和也门公民在持签证入境后在美国实施的恐怖袭击几乎为零，这项禁令对改善公共安全几乎没有实际效果。
[MUSIC, THE SUNTONES, "GIVE ME YOUR TIRED YOUR POOR"]
[音乐, THE SUNTONES, "GIVE ME YOUR TIRED YOUR POOR"]
Act Four, How Do You Solve A Problem Like Sharia?
第四幕，你怎么解决像沙里亚这样的问题？
So one thing about this executive order is that it doesn't just target people who are members of terrorist groups. It targets anybody sympathetic to their ideas. It says, quote, "the United States cannot and should not admit those who do not support the Constitution or those who would place violent ideologies over American law," which presumably is supposed to address Muslims who want to impose Sharia law. The executive order specifically mentions people who believe in honor killings, who believe in other forms of violence against women, and who believe in the persecution of those who practice religions different from their own.
所以关于这项行政命令的一件事是，它不仅仅针对那些恐怖组织成员。它针对任何同情他们想法的人。它说，引用，“美国不能也不应该接纳那些不支持宪法的人或那些将暴力意识形态置于美国法律之上的人”，这大概是为了解决那些想强加沙里亚法的穆斯林。行政命令特别提到了相信荣誉谋杀、相信其他形式针对女性的暴力行为以及相信迫害那些练习与自己不同宗教的人的人。
But the order does not say the word Muslim, and that's an important point. The administration spokespeople said a number of times this week that this executive order is not a Muslim ban. Here's White House press secretary Sean Spicer, for instance.
但命令没有提到“穆斯林”这个词，这是一个重要的点。行政发言人本周多次表示，该行政命令不是穆斯林禁令。例如，白宫新闻秘书肖恩·斯派塞。
This is not a Muslim ban. It's not a travel ban. It's a vetting system to keep America safe. That's it, plain and simple. And all of the facts--
这不是穆斯林禁令。这不是旅行禁令。这是一个保持美国安全的审查系统。就是这样，简单明了。而所有的事实——
This is the explanation over and over, in various ways and various spokespeople. This is about safety, this executive order. Sean Spicer did a pretty good job summarizing the point at a different press briefing this week.
这是反复出现的一种解释，有各种方式和各种发言人。关于安全，这项行政命令。肖恩·斯派塞在本周的另一场新闻发布会上很好地总结了这一点。
The president's going to be very proactive with protecting this country. We're not going to wait until we get attacked and figure out how we can make sure it doesn't happen again. He's going to do everything in his power to stop every threat that we face in this country and every potential threat. And that's the key point in this. How do we get ahead of threats? How do we keep America ahead of the curve when it comes to people who want to do us harm? And that's what the president--
总统在保护这个国家方面将会非常主动。我们不会等到被攻击后再想办法确保它不再发生。他将尽其所能阻止我们在这个国家面临的每一个威胁和每一个潜在威胁。这是其中的关键点。我们如何走在威胁前面？在涉及到想要伤害我们的人时，我们如何让美国保持领先？而这就是总统——
When I tried to make sense of this radical change in our immigration and anti-terrorism policy over the last weekend, I came across this article on a website that's devoted to national security law, called Lawfare, by the site's editor-in-chief, Benjamin Wittes, who I learned is usually pretty hawkish on national security issues. And he noted a bunch of things that bothered him about the executive order. He said that the drafting-- like the actual language, the writing of it-- was inept and made it prone to legal challenges. He called that, quote, "a birthday gift to the ACLU or anybody who wanted to challenge it."
当我试图在上周末理解我们移民和反恐政策的这一根本性变化时，我偶然发现了在一家致力于国家安全法的网站 Lawfare 上的一篇文章，作者是该网站的总编辑本杰明·威特斯，我了解到他通常在国家安全问题上相当强硬。他注意到了一堆让他对行政命令感到困扰的事情。他说，起草过程——比如实际的语言、写作——是无能的，并且使其容易受到法律挑战。他称之为，引用，“给美国公民自由联盟或任何想挑战它的人的生日礼物。”
But the most interesting thing he said-- he let out this argument where he said that if the real purpose of this order is to stop terrorists, like it claims, it's not going to achieve its goals. He says he didn't believe it was the executive order's real goal. He said if stopping terrorists was its goal, then the order is, quote, "wildly overinclusive and wildly underinclusive at the same time." On the underinclusive side, Wittes notes that the executive order doesn't stop people from lots of countries that might be just as likely as these seven countries to have terrorists. And on the overinclusive side, he says the order bans all kinds of people that it shouldn't, people we have no reason to suspect of being connected to terrorism. I had him read.
但他所说的最有趣的事情——他提出了一个论点，他说如果这项命令的真正目的是像它声称的那样阻止恐怖分子，它将无法实现目标。他说他不相信那是行政命令的真正目的。他说如果阻止恐怖分子是其目标，那么该命令，引用，“同时极其过度和极其不足”。在不足的一面，威特斯指出行政命令并没有阻止来自许多其他国家的可能与这七个国家一样有恐怖分子的可能性。而在过度的一面，他说该命令禁止了各种不应该禁止的人，我们没有理由怀疑与恐怖主义有关的人。我让他读了。
It for the purpose of the order is the one it describes, for example, I can think of no good reason to burden the lives of students individually suspected of nothing who are here lawfully and just happened to be temporarily overseas, or to detain tourists and refugees who were mid-flight when the order came down. I have trouble imagining any reason to raise questions about whether green card holders who have lived here for years can leave the country and then return.
如果该命令的目的是它所描述的那样，例如，我想不出有什么好的理由去负担那些被怀疑没有任何问题且只是碰巧暂时在海外的合法在此的学生的生计，或者去拘留那些在命令下来时正处于飞行途中的游客和难民。我很难想象有什么理由去提出关于那些已经在这里生活多年的绿卡持有者是否可以离开国家然后返回的疑问。
Because of that, he writes, "I don't believe that the stated purpose is the real purpose of this executive order. In the rational pursuit of security objectives, you don't marginalize your expert security agencies and fail to vet your ideas through a normal interagency process." He's referring here, I guess, to the fact that the Department of Defense, State Department, Department of Homeland Security, and other agencies were not consulted in the normal ways before this thing was released.
因此，他写道，“我不相信宣称的目的是这项行政命令的真正目的。在合理追求安全目标时，你不会边缘化你的专业安全机构，也不会不通过正常的机构间流程来审查你的想法。”他在这里指的是国防部、国务院、国土安全部和其他机构在发布这个东西之前没有以正常方式受到咨询这一事实，我想。
He writes, "you don't target the wrong people in nutty ways when you're rationally pursuing real security objectives. When do you do these things?" he writes. "You do these things when you're elevating the symbolic politics of bashing Islam over any actual security interest. This will cause hardship and misery for tens or hundreds of thousands of people because that is precisely what it is intended to do." He writes that he doesn't make this charge lightly. He's never said anything like this about any other post-9/11 measures. But that, "whatever the White House is saying this is going to do," he writes, "this will not help with terrorism, but it will keep out Muslims." and he's concluded that's its purpose.
他写道，“你在合理追求真正的安全目标时，不会以愚蠢的方式针对错误的人。你什么时候做这些事情？”他写道，“当你把抨击伊斯兰教的象征性政治置于任何实际的安全利益之上时，你就会做这些事情。这将给成千上万的人带来苦难和痛苦，因为这正是它打算做的。”他写道，他不是轻易做出这项指控的。他从未对任何其他 9/11 后的措施说过这样的话。但，“无论白宫声称这会做什么，”他写道，“这不会有助于对付恐怖主义，但它会拒穆斯林于门外。”而他得出结论那是它的目的。
Well, I think the president's told us that. I mean, I think all through the campaign he told us that he was going to stop Muslims from coming to the country. And all through the campaign, he occasionally said-- this is not a direct quote, but at one point he said, we used to call it a Muslim ban. Now we call it extreme vetting. And Rudy Giuliani said on national television that the president asked him, how do we keep out Muslims in a way that looks legal? And this order is a reflection of that. And this strikes me as different from other steps that have been taken in the post-9/11 era.
好吧，我想总统已经告诉我们了。我的意思是，我认为在整个竞选中他都告诉我们他要阻止穆斯林进入这个国家。在整个竞选中，他偶尔会说——这不是直接引用，但在某一时刻他说，我们过去称之为穆斯林禁令。现在我们称之为极端审查。而鲁迪·朱利安尼在全国电视上说，总统问他，我们如何以一种看起来合法的方式拒穆斯林于门外？而这项命令就是那的反映。这让我觉得与 9/11 后时代采取的其他步骤不同。
Did you see a senior administration official was on a conference call with reporters this week-- it was in The Washington Post-- and talked about the purpose of this executive order and very quickly got to talking about saying how the immigration system, if it wasn't changed, could lead to, quote, "the kind of large and permanent domestic terror threat that becomes multi-dimensional and multi-generational and becomes a sort of permanent feature in this case. It will become a permanent feature of American life." And what he was describing, really-- I mean, he says the phrase domestic terrorist threat, but what he's really just describing was, like, a lot of people coming into this country. He doesn't say the word Muslim, but that was the clear implication. He says, quote, "we don't want a situation where, 20, 30 years from now, it's just a given thing that, on a fairly regular basis, there's domestic terrorist strikes, that stores are shut up or airports have explosive devices planted, or people are mowed down in the street by cars and automobiles and things of that nature," the senior official said. "These are realities that we're living in today."
你有没有看到本周一位白宫高级官员在与记者的电话会议上——这在《华盛顿邮报》上——谈论了这项行政命令的目的，并很快开始谈论移民系统如果不改变，可能会导致，引用，“那种大规模且永久性的国内恐怖威胁，变得多维且多代，并成为这种情况下的一个永久特征。它将成为美国生活的一个永久特征。”而他真正描述的是——我的意思是，他说“国内恐怖威胁”这个词，但他真正描述的只是，比如，很多人来到这个国家。他没有说“穆斯林”这个词，但这暗示非常明确。他说，引用，“我们不希望 20、30 年后出现这种情况，那就是，在相当规律的基础上，发生国内恐怖袭击，商店关门或者机场被安置爆炸装置，或者人们被汽车和汽车等工具在街上碾压，”那位高级官员说。“这些是我们今天生活的现实。”
Well, I mean, look, he's talking about the terrorist consequences of admitting Muslims. Now, I first of all don't believe that that is an accurate account of Muslim immigration to the United States. I furthermore don't believe that large numbers of people in the intelligence apparatus of the United States believe that. Good counterterrorism is about scalpels. It's about distinguishing between people who pose threats and people who don't pose threats. Bad counterterrorism is about broad brushes and machetes. And we've had two administrations that have been, in different ways, careful about these distinctions.
好吧，我的意思是，看，他在谈论接纳穆斯林的恐怖主义后果。首先，我不相信那是对穆斯林移民到美国的准确描述。此外，我不相信美国情报机构中的大量人员相信这一点。好的反恐是手术刀。它在于区分构成威胁的人和不构成威胁的人。糟糕的反恐在于大刷子和砍刀。而我们有两届政府，以不同的方式，对这些区别保持谨慎。
You're talking about the Obama administration and the Bush administration before it?
你在谈论奥巴马政府和之前的布什政府？
Correct. And neither of them ever said anything that would suggest that the broad consequences of properly-vetted Muslim immigration to the United States will be to turn US cities into ungodly war zones of terrorism. And it's an irresponsible thing to say, and there is absolutely no empirical support for it.
正确。他们中没有任何人说过任何暗示经过妥善审查的穆斯林移民到美国的广泛后果会将美国城市变成不虔诚的恐怖主义战区。这是一个不负责任的说法，而且绝对没有任何经验支持。
Benjamin Wittes of Lawfare.
Lawfare 的本杰明·威特斯。
Act Five, It's Not Easy Being Green.
第五幕，成为绿色并不容易。
You might remember Abdi Nor from a show that we did a couple of years ago. He was a Somali refugee. He'd been living in Kenya, like the guys you heard at the beginning of our program today. Only Abdi got lucky. There's a thing the US has done for years, the Diversity Visa Lottery. It makes 50,000 permanent resident visas available each year around the world. And it's a real lottery. And he won and came to the United States. He's living in Portland, Maine. Reporter Leo Hornak reached out to Abdi this week to see, in light of the executive order, what Abdi is thinking.
你们可能还记得阿卜迪·诺，我们几年前做过一期关于他的节目。他是一名索马里难民。他一直住在肯尼亚，就像你们在节目开始时听到的那些人一样。只有阿卜迪比较幸运。美国多年来一直在做一件事，多元化签证抽签。它每年在全球范围内提供 50,000 个永久居民签证。这真的是一种抽签。他中奖了，来到了美国。他现在住在缅因州的波特兰。记者里奥·霍纳克本周联系了阿卜迪，想看看在行政命令的背景下，阿卜迪在想什么。
You know, I got the green card and everything has been OK until recently, when the green card issue just came up all over the media when Trump said that he-- I think they don't have an idea what the green card holders actually are. But they just made me feel not the way I felt myself when they decided that people like us would be turned from the airport.
你知道，我拿到了绿卡，一切都还好，直到最近，当特朗普说他——我想他们根本不知道绿卡持有者到底是什么人时，绿卡问题就成了媒体的焦点。但他们只是让我觉得，当他们决定像我们这样的人会被从机场遣返时，我不像我感觉到的那样了。
But if a member of the Trump administration was right here, or an official, they would say, OK, we cleared that up. You can relax. Green card holders are fine.
但如果特朗普政府的一名成员就在这里，或者一名官员，他们会说，好吧，我们澄清了。你可以放松了。绿卡持有者没问题。
I don't believe that. That's what I would say. So I've traveled to Canada before with my green card, and I've been shaking when I handed it to the lady who was at the border. And she handed it back to me, and that was totally fine. It was about two years ago. And now, I don't even want to take a risk with that. I don't want to do that because I don't want to get into trouble.
我不相信。这就是我要说的。所以我之前用绿卡去过加拿大，当把它交给边境那位女士时，我手都在抖。她把它还给了我，完全没问题。那大约是两年前的事了。现在，我甚至不想冒那个险。我不想这样做，因为我不想惹麻烦。
OK. So this travel ban is temporary and we've been told the green cards are exempt from many bans, so you should be fine. Do you have any plans to make a trip outside the country just temporarily at any point?
好的。所以这个旅行禁令是暂时的，我们被告知绿卡持有者豁免于许多禁令，所以你应该没问题。你有任何暂时出国旅行的计划吗？
Leo, this is not about the 120 days. This is not about the executive order itself. This is about who issues the executive order. I think it's about Trump. And I'm more concerned of the administration today and the way things are going. So I'm not planning to leave even after 120 days. So under Trump's administration, hell no. I'm not going nowhere.
里奥，这不是 120 天的事。这不是行政命令本身的事。这是关于是谁发出的行政命令。我想那是关于特朗普的。我对今天的政府以及事情的发展方向更加担忧。所以我甚至在 120 天后也不打算离开。所以在特朗普政府下，绝不。我哪儿也不去。
During the Trump administration, your plan is not to leave the United States at all?
在特朗普政府期间，你的计划是完全不离开美国？
That's correct, because what if, even as a citizen, I go out and something happens and then again, he says, no, Muslims cannot come back? So you know, something like that. So in Trump's administration, no, I'm not going nowhere. So from what he says, and how he executes things, and how he talks, and if you look back when he says extreme vetting-- and he really emphasizes that extreme vetting.
没错，因为如果，即使作为公民，我出去了，发生了什么事情，然后他又说，不，穆斯林不能回来？所以你知道，类似这样的事情。所以在特朗普政府下，不，我哪儿也不去。所以从他说的，以及他如何执行事情，以及他如何交谈，如果你回看他说“极端审查”时——而且他确实强调了那个极端审查。
And remember, I'm a Somali. I come from Somalia, one of the countries that he really doesn't like. And he came to Portland, the city where I live, [? twice, ?] and talked about the Somalis as bad people who were just coming to this country, and they have to be stopped. That rhetoric and the actions that he's now doing-- I think that, at one point, he's going to do something that will directly affect me. I don't know what it's going to be, but I'm really worried.
而且记住，我是索马里人。我来自索马里，他非常不喜欢的国家之一。他来到波特兰，我住的城市，[两次？]，谈论索马里人是即将来到这个国家的坏人，他们必须被阻止。那种修辞和他现在正在采取的行动——我觉得，在某一时刻，他会做一些直接影响我的事情。我不知道那会是什么，但我真的很担心。
Abdi Nor. He's writing a book about his life as a refugee. Leo Hornak is a BBC reporter for PRI's The World.
阿卜迪·诺。他正在写一本关于他难民生活的书。里奥·霍纳克是 PRI《世界》节目的 BBC 记者。
[MUSIC - BRETT HARRIS, "UP IN THE AIR"]
[音乐 - BRETT HARRIS, "UP IN THE AIR"]
Our program was produced today by Zoe Chace and myself. Our production staff, Susan Burton, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, and Diane Wu. Research help today from Christopher Swetala, Michelle Harris, and Ben Phelan. Music help today from Damien Graef.
今天的节目由佐伊·蔡斯和我制作。我们的制作人员，苏珊·伯顿、达纳·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明、卡伦·达芬、斯蒂芬妮·富、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、大卫·克斯滕鲍姆、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、马特·蒂尔尼、南希·厄普代克和戴安·吴。今天的研究帮助来自克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、米歇尔·哈里斯和本·费伦。今天的音乐帮助来自达米安·格拉夫。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, somebody stole his kayak for the weekend and then brought it back, and Torey thinks it was a Somali pirates. But he doesn't know how to catch them.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由 PRX，公共广播交流中心，发送到公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，有人周末偷了他的皮划艇然后又把它还回来了，而托雷认为那是索马里海盗。但他不知道怎么抓住他们。
What are we going to do, run somebody's fingerprints through the Mogadishu DMV?
我们要怎么做，通过摩加迪沙车管所查询某人的指纹吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。